[Music]
yep that's the cast of Zoey 101 - Jamie
Lynn Spears on Tuesday Spears shared
this video message from her former
castmates along with their theme song
sing-along she captioned the clip quote
not only did I miss the reunion but I
also missed the FaceTime because I'm
lame and fell asleep thank you all for
the video and hope to see y'all very
soon Victoria Justice teased the meet-up
on her instace Tori so right now I am
headed to a very special dinner
I'm very excited
[Music]
and the caste shared tons of pics once
they were all together all the main
players were there
Paul butcher aka Dustin I'm here
Chris Macey who played Michael Aaron
Sanders better known as Quinn these are
small spherical explosives I made out of
plutonium Matt Underwood who played
Logan on screen Sean Flynn aka chase all
right okay Abbey Wilde who played Stacee
Jaxx Salvatore jr. aka mark and Victoria
Justice who we all loved as Lola you can
either be in charge of getting the
photographer or ice ice you know frozen
water the cast reunion comes on the
heels of reports that claimed Spears was
in talks to reprise her role as Zoey
Brooks more than 10 years after zoey 101
ended it's four season run in 2008 the
actress took to Instagram to address the
rumors and let everyone know she is
totally down writing yo Nickelodeon have
your people call my people
hashtags Zoey 101 Zoey something's
bothering you yeah you figure out what
it is let me know in January the 28 year
old celebrated the 14 year anniversary
of the show's premier with a post
praising the show's theme song follow me
saying it was quote still a jam
[Music]